here's how the vw beetle became one of
the best selling cars of all time
instead of saying hey we're fuel
efficient and we're sturdy and the same
things that everyone else said they just
said it'll stay ugly longer and the
reason that that worked so well it was
something called a damaging admission
they actually set a negative first
people who speak about their own
negatives as more trustworthy if you
actually want to use this in your own
business you can just say something
negative before you say something
positive you'll be more persuasive but
if you say something negative that
relates and could be flipped as a
positive thing it actually makes it even
more persuasive for example if i had a
very small facility where i did my
business i might say hey it's really
small on here you're definitely not
gonna be able to fit a lot of stuff i
was like we're nice and cozy if i can
flip the positive is negative which most
negatives do have positive elements you
make it more persuasive and more
likeable and more trustworthy all by
taking the things that you used to be
afraid of and putting them out there